MANU BATRA: Welcome
folks, to KubeCon.
My name is Manu Batra.
I'm the product manager
for Anthos Storage.
JING XU: My name is Jing, so I
am Kubernetes Storage Lifecycle
Team at Google.
MANU BATRA: Our
session at KubeCon
was about when you're
coming from a virtual world,
how do you look at
Kubernetes and storage?
So, I spent 20 years
working on storage,
but when I moved
into Kubernetes,
I was really looking for a cheat
sheet somebody could walk me
through to say, how
should I approach storage?
How should I look at--
how do I translate A to B?
So, the talk focuses more
around why does Kubernetes
need storage?
When do you need storage
for admin clusters
and also for workflow clusters?
Then we draw
parallels between when
you look at architectural
parallels between how
does working machines approach
storage versus containers
approach storage?
So, Jing, do you want to
talk about competitive
versus declarative models?
JING XU: Sure.
So in the traditional
way of managing systems,
we have imperative APIs.
So, for example, if
you want a new disk,
you perform that task.
If it fails, you try again.
Kubernetes is now
completely changing
the way you're managing
with declarative APIs.
So, basically, it means you
just describe what the system
state is and the controller
will automatically reconcile
until it reaches this state.
If anything goes
wrong, it will try
to reconcile again until it
reaches this desired state.
So it will attempt
automatically.
MANU BATRA: Perfect.
So next we move on to
comparing and drawing parallels
between the operational states.
So, looking at Day 2
operations, about allocations
of volumes, what are the
different ways containers
allow you or Kubernetes allows
you to map those volumes?
And some of the
things we talk about
is, how do you look at
dynamic provisioning
versus static provisioning?
So do you want to talk
about some details?
JING XU: Yeah, sure.
For static provisioning,
we mean the sysadmin has
to create, allocate,
partition the disk,
and then the user will use that.
But dynamic provisioning means
when the user has a request,
the storage will be
created on demand.
So it's done dynamically
instead of preallocated.
MANU BATRA: And those models
are really critical as you are
deploying container workloads in
cloud or on-prem because those
models really--
Day 1 and Day 2 operations
differ greatly on those models.
And in the end,
you really walk out
with a quick cheat sheet of--
I'm coming from Planet
A going to Planet B,
and I'll still be
living on both sides,
but how do I do that translation
between a terminology
cheat sheet on what does
A mean in containers,
and how do I translate to
something that I'm already
familiar with?
And I can [INAUDIBLE]
much better
and translate those
things across.
So, thank you for
listening to our talk.
Again, we have a
booth at KubeCon.
Please stop by and feel free
to ask us any questions.
We'll be right here.
And welcome to KubeCon.
JING XU: Yeah, we'll have some
time to talk tomorrow, too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]